well science is telling us that we can
do phenomenal things if we put our minds
and our resources to us I mean I think
science is probably the best example of
you put resources into something and you
let the creativity and the brilliance of
the minds throughout the world and
certainly not only in this country
throughout the world and phenomenally
good things can happen you've got to
make sure that there's checks and
balances on that because science can
also lead to things that are not so good
you know and there's the whole ethical
issues of manipulating at the genomic at
the genomic level the whole issues of
embryos and creating people to your own
fashionable boutique liking all those
things you've got to really be very very
careful at but science at its most pure
where you're swinging for discovery and
you're going to use discovery for the
betterment of mankind I think science
stands out among what some of the most
important endeavors that the humankind
can pursue mankind evolves I mean
there's no doubt that we have evolved
the whole issue of evolving through
various lower species to our own species
of the human but there's also the
continuing evolution that is associated
with mankind and a lot of that is using
what specifically and particularly and
peculiarly makes you a human being and
that is your intellect and your will you
have a choice you can analyze things and
you can act in an intellectual manner
and that is to me that the very
foundation of what science is how you
can better your own lot the lot of the
other citizens of the world while you're
paying attention to and preserving the
world you live in which is the reason
why things like the environment are so
so important when we try and analyze all
we doing things that are detrimental to
the environment and if so how do we stop
it and if we have to stop it how do we
replace it with something
that's environmentally friendly and I
think science is going to lead us there
and it's the goodwill that you have to
try and preserve your own species as
well as preserve the environment IE our
planet so that we can have thousands and
more years of people doing good things
in leading good lives